[Music]
[Music]
for centuries no human has had the power
to become a monster
until now behold the transformation ray
awesome but is this safe though let's
find out
[Music]
is everything okay down here hey drac
what's up
johnny oops
[Music]
what's going on i used van helsing's
transforming ring
dad you're human drag oh no
i have a total dad bod
um what is going on
[Music]
what's up
who are those guys it's me uncle griffin
you don't recognize me i've
literally never seen you before
we need to find a way to fix this there
is a place
deep in the amazon only there can the
transformations be reversed
time to go
wow flying his monster is so much better
right
you're not a vampire the sun won't fry
you now it's glorious
it's wondrous it's it's
burning my eye
if we don't fix you guys soon you'll be
like this forever seriously
everybody relax just enjoy the view
ugh please being a human is the worst
can't swim can't relax
mosquitoes
hotel transylvania transfer mania boy
that was fun
the only place to experience transfer
mania is in a movie theater october 1st
[Music]
here's to hotel transylvania
johnny works so hard to make this extra
special
okay thank you dear son-in-law
ruined everything johnny what are you
talking about your dad never really
thought of me as part of the family
all because i'm not a monster so you
want to become a monster huh
van helsing demonstration ray turns
humans into monsters and monsters into
humans but is this safe though
great question
that's weird nothing happened
[Music]
the nightmare it's over i'm human again
hey jack what's up johnny oh no
[Music]
you're a human and i'm a monster it's
like freaky friday but on a tuesday
though
what's going on
my first
what's up fellas frank oh i'm balding
[Music]
bye